la bienvenue avec nous sur rt france
alors avant que l'accord de double a été
signé ou bien de le dire on le qualifie
alors d'accord historique où emmener
actuellement la mise en oeuvre de cet
accord de paix
c'est certainement en effet un accord
historique parce que ça avait permis de
réunir les groupes rebelles avec toutes
les forces du changement les forces
armées du pays et donc il ya un document
qui a été établi qu est un document
extrêmement complet détaillé pour
déterminer quelle va être
la nouvelle constitution du soudan d'une
certaine manière mais au bout d'un an il
faut bien dire que cet accord n'a été
que très a complètement
mises en oeuvre dans la mesure où
certainement des places ont été
réservées aux régions qui étaient
autrefois tenu par les groupes rebelles
au sein du gouvernement
au sein des instances supérieures du
pays mais
l'idée centrale de cet accord c'est que
le soudan devienne un d'état fédérale et
sa demande des réformes
constitutionnelles qui n'ont pas eu lieu
jusqu'à présent et puis il ya aussi la
légitimité de cet accord qui est mise en
cause par certains des signataires comme
par d'autres groupes dans la mesure où
le soudan est en phase de transition
démocratique avec un gouvernement civil
mais aussi un conseil de souveraineté où
se trouvent des militaires et puis des
forces armées des forces de sécurité qui
participent de manière un petit peu
attentiste à cette marche des événements
et un gouvernement qui lui aussi assez
difficile donc il n'y a pas de
légitimité démocratique si vous voulez à
cet accord jusqu'à présent
tous les groupes rebelles ont signé cet
accord parce que manifestement fait ce
qu'on pose problème aujourd'hui
oui il ya cette dimension qui est
souvent mise en avant rennes le groupe
rebelle qui tient les monts nuba au
centre du pays a refusé jusqu'à présent
de signer cet accord dans la mesure où
il fait un préalable de la séparation de
la religion et de l'état et ça ça n'est
pas prévu
liberté de religion évidemment proclamer
mais la séparation de la religion et de
l'état sert de l'islam finalement et de
l'état à la suite de 30 ans d'un régime
islamiste extrêmement répressif à
l'égard non seulement des chrétiens des
animistes mais aussi des musulmans eh
bien ça a laissé des traces dans le pays
et jusqu'à présent il ya un doute qui
subsiste si vous voulez dans ces
proclamations d'intention de séparer la
religion de l'état donc comme plusieurs
fois les groupes rebelles mais aussi la
population soudanaise a été trompé par
les autorités qui promettait de séparer
la religion de l'état
cette fois-ci chat échaudé craint l'eau
froide et donc ils en font un préalable
d'autres groupes au darfour considère
que la situation n'est pas réglée n'est
pas stabilisé que ce qui est proposé
comme forme de gouvernement du darfour
de cette grande région de l'ouest du
pays qui a été victime on a dit à
l'époque de génocide un ya 20 ans mais
en tout cas où il ya encore des
centaines de milliers de réfugiés qui ne
sont pas rentrés chez eux où il ya
encore beaucoup de violence de massacres
même dans cette région depuis un an eh
bien il ya un groupe en particulier
mouvement de libération du soudan qui
était le premier groupe à prendre les
armes contre le bus en mode khartoum en
2002 et bien qu'il refusait de signer
cet accord très rapidement l'arc laval
parce qu'on est pressé par le temps on
sait qu'il faut d'importantes ressources
financières
pour mettre en l'application d'accords
de paix et on connaît la situation
économique un très très délicat du
soudan
oui la livre soudanaise s'est effondré
l'économie est à genoux mais je ne suis
pas sûr que cette dimension financière
soit la première c'est à dire que la
pauvreté peut être partagée si vous
voulez entre la région centrale et les
régions périphériques qui ont encore
moins que la région centrale donc tout
ça effectivement dépend un peu de l'aide
internationale ou de l'insertion du
soudan dans les circuits financiers
internationaux mais ce n'est pas
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est d'avancer
sur la transition démocratique qui a été
promise il ya en même temps que deux ans
marc lavergne merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct sur rt france rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche cnrs et
spécialiste du soudan et de la corne de
l'afrique